et voilà donc un affrontement
idéologique entre deux crans au soir
dans le cadre de la campagne
présidentielle faut-il interdire la
chasse le week-end comme le demande le
candidat d'europe écologie les verts
yannick jadot ou au contraire faut-il
créer un grand ministère de la ruralité
indépendant de l'environnement comme le
demandent les chasseurs c'est l'objet de
notre face à face
avec nous pourrons parler ce soir eddy
puyjalon président du mouvement de la
ruralité bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur ce plateau pour nous
accompagner philippe bourrier achi
conseiller régional europe écologie en
ile-de-france bonsoir philippe breuil
accès vers 6 d'être avec nous un mot
tout d'abord à je vous ai vu voilà un
type accusé le coup parce que c'est vrai
que il mâche pas ses mots ce chasseur
écologistes et anti chasse est différent
il parle d' escroc logis ou qu'est ce
que vous répondez et surtout qu'est ce
qu'il entend par là c'est surtout à lui
qu'il faut poser la question qu'est ce
qu'il entend par là en tout cas moi ce
que je peux dire sur les propos qu'on a
entendu évidemment condamne nous les
écologistes toute forme de violence et
je les invite à regarder les vidéos de
ses amis les chasseurs comment ils
maltraitent les militants écologistes
qui essaye de faire prendre conscience
et qui demandent juste à pouvoir
bénéficier de la nature comme tout le
monde et se balader en sécurité eddie f
et g long escrocs logis vos enfants à
leurs employés ce thème également vous
étiez d'accord avec toutes les critiques
ce témoin aux écologistes
parti oui évidemment sur la partie
gestion des territoires
vie sociétale dans la ruralité mais
après la partie écologie ou escroc logis
l et es les limites entre guillemets
parce que parfois on voit bien
l'écologie politique a besoin d'exister
et de faire un peu de trash et de remuer
les choses je pense que yannick jadot et
en 2016 expliqué que son grand père
était chasseur qu'il comprenait la
chasse même s'il ya des situations où
des espèces qui comprenait pas qu'on
chasse ou tel type de mode de chasse
mais il avait un discours bout ou plus
souple qu'il ne l'a aujourd'hui alors je
pense qu'aujourd'hui évidemment le sujet
devient très prégnant il ya le parti
animalistes il ya un monsieur mélenchon
qui fait de la surenchère et donc tout
le monde fait de la surenchère dans ce
canton à se présenter à la présidence de
la république on essaie plutôt de
rassembler les français d'abord le
discours rassembleur d'y mettre des
règles mais voilà faire de la
ségrégation m'expliquer que les
chasseurs n'ont pas leur place le
week-end ou pendant les vacances
scolaires je vous le saviez que parce
que moi je suis né dans la ruralité
j'adore les gens qui viennent en
vacances chez nous on discute et puis il
ya des règles à mettre en place alors
permettez voir juste de dire quand même
et j'ai une pensée pour les deux
personnes blessées que je lance un coup
de gueule aussi aux chasseurs entrant je
leur demande de faire très très
attention de privilégier la sécurité de
faire toujours attention alors à leurs
tirs mais il faut savoir aussi une chose
que j'aime bien notre ami le
représentant de jean paul cluzel c'est
que c'est quand même le monde de
l'écologie qui a demandé aux chasseurs
d'abandonner un certainement de tir de
passer avec des armes très puissante la
chasse en quelques années à faire un
effort considérable c'est comme si vous
demandiez aux automobilistes trouvés y
avait 600 chevaux sous le capot on a eu
des armes très puissante qui a fallu
faire baisser les accidents on est
arrivé aujourd'hui à 10 accidents de
trop aux parents mais voilà c'est une
c'est une chose qui est assez compliquée
à gérer il ya beaucoup de grands gibiers
il faut assurer ce set c'est
probablement dans des conditions très
particulières avait beaucoup de routes
et des habitations il ya des règles qui
sont draconiennes mais encore une fois
de plus ça ne justifie rien il faut zéro
accident il faut toujours penser que
quand on a une arme à la main on doit
savoir ce que l'on fait comme on le fait
et quitte à ne pas tirer il faut être
dans de sécurité donc on a pensé à ces
deux personnes toujours deux personnes
de trop mais voilà je pense que les gens
peuvent vivent parfaitement nos finances
il ya aujourd'hui sur les territoires la
possibilité de se retrouver dans la
nature cavaliers randonneurs
naturaliste photographe chasseurs
évidemment que ça fait un long 10 sur 11
mois je veux dire un million de
pratiquants savait où 974 personnes
renversées sur les pas des cyclistes est
ce qu'on va interdire le week-end la
voiture pendant les vacances je pense
pas encore une fois de plus ce même les
trottinettes aujourd'hui on voit qu'il
ya des gens qui trottinent à sur la
route mais on va essayer de mettre des
bandes fluo faire monter la sécurité
pour le moins d'accidents possible parce
que des jeunes qui se sont renversés
c'est toujours désagréable et donc voilà
le vivre ensemble ben il faut faire
monter la sécurité c'est notre rôle à
tous à chacun et puis il a fini bon
vieil chine y'a quand même effectivement
c'est ce que dit notre ami disons qu'on
a entendu aussi et dans ce témoignage
une forme le sentiment d'une forme
d'acharnement tout ce qui touche à la
nature
qu'est ce que vous répondez
à cela
tout simplement on est vraiment désolé
s'il pense qu'ils sont acharnées mais
nous les écologistes nous aimons avant
tout le vivant tous les vivants et les
animaux font partie du corps des vivants
on ne veut pas embêter les salles les
chasseurs sauf monsieur a parlé de deux
accidents quand même leur interdire la
chasse le week-end et pendant les
vacances scolaires
il ya sept jours dans la semaine du
lundi au vendredi sans les cinq ça leur
laisse déjà pas mal de de plaisir et de
loisirs visiblement puisque c'est plutôt
un loisir le rappeler quelques chiffres
en deux entre 2019 et 2020 il ya eu 131
blessés et onze morts en 2020 2021 or
selon qui les locaux vides il ya eu 80
blessées et sept morts alors on peut
parler d'accidents lorsque c'est une
fois et c'est spontané mais lorsque
c'est répétitif je ne veux pas aller
jusqu à outrager monsieur et ses amis
les chasseurs on peut considérer que là
il ya des homicides volontaires parce
que lorsqu'on met une arme entre les
mains j'ai entendu parler de prélèvement
lorsqu'on met une arme par destination
elle ôte la vie alors
des victimes par son chasseur d'autant
plus de prendre cette conscience cette
conscience collective on a entendu
parler que les mentalités changent bas
ça tombe bien c'était une phrase de
sandrine rousseau pour dire les temps
changent quand on parle de prélèvement
j'aurais rappelé
monsieur le président que 20 millions
d'animaux sont élevées à destination de
la chasse je voudrais entendre aussi
pourquoi les chasseurs ont besoin de
nourrir les sangliers et les cerfs pour
pouvoir donc parce que plus vous allez
nourrir pub où ils vont se développer et
donc plus vous avez besoin de faire des
prélèvements je crois qu'il est temps
que maintenant que les usagers de la
nature les citoyens les femmes les
enfants puissent se promener cueillir
des champignons sans se dire aujourd'hui
à un membre de notre famille va finir à
l'hôpital pour détresse vitale ou alors
à la morgue alors c'est vrai qu'elle
attendait on va vous passez la parole
pardonnez moi eric rouiller et puis
j'adore je voudrais quand même regarder
en ces quelques messages parce qu'elle a
eu beaucoup tout au long de la journée
manifestement c'est un débat là qui crée
la passion toujours et encore pour eric
oui la forêt appartient aussi aux
promeneurs la quasi-totalité des forêts
sont privés en france autre position non
il ne faut pas interdire la chasse le
week-end c'est absurde la chasse est
indispensable c'est vrai que on a
toujours le sentiment qui est un peu
deux camps quand on parle de ce débat
sur les chasseurs pourquoi autant de
passion il dit puijalon parce que je
pense que
l'écologie politique et nos fait on ne
filme une tête de turc les chasseurs et
ont fait monter une sorte de haine et
les gens viennent se défouler
aujourd'hui donc c'est facile d'agresser
un chasseur de comme un agriculteur
aujourd'hui malheureusement les éleveurs
sont aujourd'hui à gressier les des
agriculteurs sur leur tracteur prennent
les découpes fut des coups de poing dans
la figure parce que ils s'entraînent au
traité leurs vinyles par exemple c'est
aujourd'hui une maladie qu a été mis en
place par les gens de l'écologie en
remettra en montrant du doigt des gens
qui ne méritent pas quand on sauve des
vies parce que on a pu lire réguler les
sangliers en bordure d'autoroute ou de
route et qu'on sait très bien qu'il ya
des accidents mortels mortel avec les
grands gibiers quand on fait du travail
pour réguler pour empêcher qu'il ya des
dégâts agricoles et les agriculteurs
n'avaient plus on vient pas voir si le
chasseur fait son boulot et qu'il est là
pour réguler les granvillais
on est en train de l'agresser en disant
on protège le vivre je suppose que si on
continue comme le dit monsieur et
certaines de ses amies qui sont en train
de vouloir protéger la punaise de lit
mais de mer on va pouvoir toucher une
source qu'un moustique quoi je veux dire
c'est ça devient que tout et n'importe
quoi le évidemment que le vivais en est
important mais on ne peut pas non plus
considérer que l'homme ne fait pas
partie du bilan merci merci merci
justement de considérer non vous pousser
à
l'extrême et j'entends vous êtes en
train de défendre votre paroisse et vos
vos soutiens et ceux de votre parti
politique on a vu d'ailleurs votre vidéo
des voeux où vous en guidant hollande et
vos collègues parce qu'il n'était pas
assez présent et manifestations et ça je
peux l'entendre qui a un désamour ou d
intéressement de nouveaux clients ou de
vos patients ou de vos collègues vu
l'âge élevé de ceux et celles qui
pratiquent ce n'est pas moi qui le dit
c'est la fédération des chasseurs
monsieur on veut pas vous déranger on
veut pas vous embêter mais pouvez-vous
comprendre qu'il faut que nous
partagions un espace commun que le
bien-être du des gens qui se promène en
forêt qui prennent ce grand bol d'air ce
grand antidépresseurs gratuit et naturel
vous pouvez l'entendre ça vous savez que
celui qui a été grièvement blessé il est
entre la vie et la mort et moi je veux
avoir une pensée pour lui et pour sa
famille qui doivent être dans tous leurs
états ils étaient ils étaient en voiture
sur la quatre voies entre rennes et
nantes
il n'était pas dans la forêt donc là on
peut plus d'accidents il faut réellement
ensemble console on s'assoit à la tout
autour d'une table que vous discutiez
avec yannick jadot de discuter avec mm
macro qui vous fait des belles courbes
est pour avoir vous voix pour les
élections discuter les écologistes
discuter que l'association one voice
discuter avec l 214 discuter avec 6
schipper discuter si vous voulez pas
parler avec nous parler avec les
associations moi je vous invite à
discuter weiss et vous verrez peut-être
que vous changerez d'avis il est plein
de jeux intelligents mais à condition
qu'ils aient pas d'intégrisme et de
malhonnêteté quand on est ouverts vers
les autres et c'est tout en interdisant
aux vêtements moi je crois que du débat
de du respect de chacun on arrive
toujours à grandir les choses sauf qu'en
réalité on a très bien vu qu'aujourd'hui
les gens attise les ailes il ya des
groupuscules aujourd'hui qui sont là
depuis très longtemps si elle est très
bien là et l'a fait comme soul
nous condamnons nous condamnons méfier
mais tout aussi bien et toute forme de
violence quelques années lorsque votre
discours et que vous ne vouliez ou non
quand hellénique janaudy jadot lit il va
falloir interdire la chasse que week end
et pendant les vacances scolaires vous
stigmatisez et donc vous rajoutez une
couche aux gens qui se permettent
aujourd'hui dans le sud-waziristan les
côtés monsieur le maire si dense et nous
voulons juste content et j'ai une
famille il faut s'il faut partager cet
espace nous proposons de l'état je ne
voulais pas voulez vous le voulez ainsi
d'être sans cesse que je vous dise ado
dit autre chose
décidément c'est cette question de la
chasse et dans toutes les campagnes
présidentielle et ça ne va pas manquer
cette fois ci encore je vous propose
justement d'écouté yannick jadot
la justice française qui a
systématiquement les décrets du
gouvernement sur la chasse des animaux
protégés emmanuel macron est un
président sous influence du lobby de la
chasse j'interdirais la chasse le
week-end et pendant les vacances
scolaires
lobby de la chasse et des jalons déjà
monsieur jadot il dit des bêtises dans
une seule phrase non on ne chasse pas
les espèces protégées quintaux par les
halles où elle peut rien c'est une
espèce chasse au fusil en l'occurrence
les choses traditionnelles ou est
interdite sur une pratique de chasse au
filet ancestrale mais en aucune manière
ce sont des espèces protégées on a
encore des choses qui sont des contre
vérités sur le fait que que monsieur
macron défendre les chasseurs en
particulier oui il en a fait et il en a
fait certaines certaines faveurs notre
billet mais sur sur le permis de chasse
il il sait aussi l'utilité
de parmi 10
sur le permis nationale messieurs mais
vous savez comme bien des gens prennent
le permis national la chasse populaire
que l'on pratique d'un au sud de la
france ou même dans toute la france ce
sont d'abord des salariés les voiliers
qui prennent pas un permis national donc
le permis est resté au même prix que
j'espère qu'on fera ference est-ce que
vous avez défendu
cette chasse aux rides qui est la chasse
à glu pour mes lectures et edwin bourget
ce qu'ils appellent leurs congénères
pour que vous puissiez des tirés à 1,5
dit m enfin franchement ce sont des
méthodes
vous êtes d'accord
qui est sous l'influencé du lobby des
chasseurs naudy yannick jadot ce serait
pas le premier ni le dernier au public
puisque on dit tout le temps que ce
lobby est très puissant est ce que c'est
c'est eh bien vous l'avez constaté vous
sûr on l'a vu très puissant et très
violent je vous invite à regarder à
nouveau ne serait ce que les vidéos de
laval qui manifestent contre les chasses
à courre et comment sont reçus les
militants écologistes et est donc tous
les présidents le font de manière
rectorat mais aussi ont peur vous avez
un million de personnes armées de fusils
vous n'avez pas trop envie de vous
frotter elle alors les écologistes c'est
vrai que c'est beaucoup plus simple
d'aller leur taper dessus parce qu'ils
sont pacifiques et qui vous reçoivent
des fleurs et des bonbons vous inversez
les rôles la chasse est une activité
légale le délit d'un troc et devrait
être beaucoup plus mises en place
aujourd'hui et plus responsable ce
s'habituerait les affrontements et des
risques de débordements on n'est pas là
fait je sais pas si vous consommez que
un citoyen un groupe de citoyens peut
aller demain dans une boucherie
charcuterie interview un boucher
charcutier le travail est un chasseur de
pratiquer un pêcheur de pratiquer sous
l'égide qu'il pense que lui et pas
d'accord ça devient de l'anarchie moi je
vais traiter les agglomérations de
manacor ici sinon nouvelle monsieur le
président monsieur régionales
pensez-vous pression est ce que pour
rabat vous mal bougé disait monsieur le
président vous m'avez dit que vous
aimiez le vivent tous les vivants je
suppose que vous devez aimer les animaux
monsieur le président quel effet que ça
fait d'être une proie inoffensif avec
une meute de chiens et de chats soeur je
parle essentiellement de la chasse à
courre le stress que ces animaux vivent
avant d'arriver à la donner à la
souffrance monsieur le président un peu
gênant si vous tuez vous me fait sourire
sur le sujet vous n en ai pas dit devant
les loups que vous êtes en train de
remettre en place le pays
qu'ils sont en train de chasser en meute
sur des troupeaux de moutons mais aussi
sur de grands gibiers et là vous trouvez
le rayon sauvagement de la nature
tellement bon que vous voyez pas de
souffrance voyez même pas la souffrance
des éleveurs et vous venez critiquer
quelqu'un qui pratique une chasse à
courre sur un cerf qui a toutes ses
chances et de toute manière qui ne
reproduit que l'activité naturelle qui
ce feeling avec les grands prédateurs
mais vous vous sortez l'homme de l'un
des grands prédateurs naturels des
maisons au moins verte et l'homme est
comme un rêve planeur qui a besoin que
la chasse a t il été aussi on sait tout
le business qui a autour de la chasse
est lourde pour un loisir et pour un
plaisir aussi morbide zombies avec un
tube vous avez une vision et c'est votre
choix permettez-nous de la dénoncer de
dénoncer cette barbarie et de s'opposer
c'est démarrer un futur présent la
public qui a le courage de se poser un
futur précédent la future maison de la
république qui s'opposent à cette forme
de barbarie qui fait de la surenchère
pour essayer de remonter un peu dans les
sondages le candidat qui a proposé
d'abolir totalement la chasse s'il avait
voulu faire la surenchère il serait
monté un
candidat toujours à moitié déclaré on va
dire je vous propose d'écouter eric
zemmour ce qu'ils en pensent
ce sont des bobos des villes qui font la
morale aux français deschamps les
attaques répétées des écologistes contre
la chasse est d'abord l'expression de
leur mépris pour la france et ses
traditions pourriez si elle est
importante enfin pas importante non
intéressante cette cette phrase parce
que ça montre cette espèce vol hard de
la france séparé en deux deux camps
qu'est ce que vous répondez à cette
analyse eric zemmour je réponds à
monsieur et moi j'étais en cure puisque
pendant deux jours j'ai pas entendu
parler de zemmour donc ça me remet ça me
remet une piqûre je lui réponds que 80%
des français veulent abolir la chasse
est donc pour un demi candidat qu'il est
aujourd'hui sans vouloir lui manquer de
respect il n'entend pas cette majorité
de français qui vient de s'exprimer donc
ça laisse pas présager de mauvaises
conditions si ce monsieur arriver aux
plus grandes fonctions
un mot de la fin
c'est absolument désolant jeu il me
semble que je vois des partis politiques
qui ne sont là que pour courir après
leurs chapelles qui ne sont pas là pour
pratiquer le vivre ensemble est encore
une fois de plus - milieu rural que ce
soit un maire qui soient chasseurs un
docteur on a toutes les classes de la
société qui les qui pratiquent cette
belle passion et croyez bien que les
gens qui viennent de la ville quand ils
viennent auprès des gens qui sont
chasseurs les apprécie et qui revoit un
peu les considérations que font par vos
méthodes et épi part bondi sur 506 fn le
président ça va être très agréable dé
lever 20 millions d'oiseaux d'ouvrir la
cage de les laisser sans voleurs ont
sombré dans le sketch des inconnus avec
la galinette cendrée
de drôles de
quentin je vous dirai pourquoi c'est
utile parce que c'est un pêche de de
prélever d'un certain à certaines
biodiversité certes un lâcher de faisans
évite de aux jeunes de prendre des
perdrix ou autre chose c'est quand même
un prélèvement qui est fait comme si
vous preniez le poulet vous achetez un
débat finalement vous les élever si
monsieur le président 20 millions
d'animaux disent qu'il faut de nourrir
et pour désiré à ce port est une
pratique de quelques personnes que vous
avez invité d'ailleurs les propos d'eric
zemmour à venir chasser de moutons de
brebis de vous deux vaches des cochons
élevés en france pour l'étudier des
marchés bafin rien de plus naturel
messieurs en plus nous les pratiquons
nous prend nous mêmes et d'efforts les
offres des fonds les consoles nous mêmes
c'était quelque chose d'agréable on
jouait lui dit de la grève et si c'est
agréable aller directement au
supermarché ou à la boucherie ou ou chez
le voilà lié à acheter votre votre belle
et pour le déguster avec vos années
n'assumez pas moi j'assume mon rôle de
chasseur et de prédateur je prends mon
viguier je le consomment et généfique un
geste naturel vous vous faites l'amour
par procuration et encore vous n'êtes
pas dans les esprits mais ceux qui
considèrent qu'il faut plus manger
devient d'élevage et magie que la viande
cellulaire
j'espère que pour vous ce n'est pas le
cas et que vous considérez que l'élevage
en france est quelque chose d'important
merci en tout cas tous les deux dit a
plu à l'onf il est pas bon gâchis on
termine sur ce message d'un
téléspectateur pascal du millas ma
dernière non promenade en forêt qui fut
en semaine on m'a vivement conseillé de
porter un gilet jaune
peut-être est-ce également la meilleure
solution en week-end dans la cité la
conclusion